[تصفيق]
لشجعته في الدفاع عن بلاده يمنح الرئيس
الاوكراني لقب شخصيه العام 2022 وهو فلودو
ملزمه يتصدر الصفحه الاولى لمجله تايم
الامريكيه تماما كالرئيس الروسي بالادمير
بوتين الذي حاز على نفس اللقب عام 2007
ان الشجاعه يمكن ان تكون معديه كالخوفا
لحظ الناس والدول على الاتحاد للدفاع عن
الحريه ولتذكير العالم بهاشاشه
الديمقراطيه والسلامه
المدنيين والمتطوعين الذين كرثوا حياتهم
للدفاع عن بلادهم كالطبيبه ارينا
توفيق التي ساعدت الامهات على الولاده
اثناء القسم
الذي بفضله البلاد على شبكه الانترنت
ومنذ عام
1927 تختار المجله قبل نهايه العام شخصيه
او مجموعه تميزت بتاثيرها السلبي او
الايجابيه على العالم فكان اللقب من نصيب
العديد من الرؤساء الامريكيين كجبايدن
ودونالد ترامب وبراك اوباما وجورج بوش
وجورج دبليو بوش الذي حاز على اللقب مرتين
تماما كبلك الانترنت شخصيات تونسيه
واجتماعيه اختارتها المجله الامريكيه كائن
ماسك وغندي والملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
والخميني